the sentence for murder is life
imprisonment the minimum term will be 14
years
the time which you've spent on remand
238 days will be deducted from the time
you must now serve making a net minimum
term of 13 years and 127 days if that
figure is wrong for any reason it can be
corrected administratively it's
important that you and everyone involved
with this case should understand what
this means the minimum term is not a
fixed term after which you'll be
automatically released it's the minimum
time you'll spend in custody in full
before your case can be considered by
the parole board
it will be for them to say whether and
if so on what conditions you're to be
released
if and when you are released you'll be
subject to license for the rest of your
life if you were to breach any condition
of a license the license could be
revoked and you would be recalled to
prison
and if the surcharge applies an order
will be drawn up accordingly
that concludes my sentencing remarks